Seamos honestos.
La atroz e infame invasión de Ucrania fue
toda una sorpresa para la inmensa mayor parte
de todos los analistas, expertos y periodistas
tanto en el campo militar como en la política
internacional.
Y en cierto modo nosotros no somos una excepción.
Lo cierto es que una invasión a gran escala
parecía algo impensable.
Una intervención militar como esta, con frentes,
bombardeo de ciudades y tropas desplegadas
a lo largo y ancho de toda Ucrania no parecía
un escenario factible.
Básicamente porque nadie esperaba que Vladimir
Putín se pegara un tiro en el pie como este.
(La invasión de Ucrania y las consiguientes
sanciones internacionales han puesto contra
las cuerdas a la economía rusa y lo han apartado
del resto del mundo.
Convertirse en el país agresor por excelencia
ha sido una de las decisiones más absurdas
que se recuerdan en la escena internacional.
En Ucrania Rusia no tenía nada que ganar
y sí mucho que perder.
Y no se trata solo de las sanciones o de las
bajas militares sufridas.
La invasión de Rusia también ha cohesionado
a la OTAN, fortalecido el eje atlántico y
animado a los europeos a gastar más para
reconstruir sus fuerzas armadas.)
La guerra de Ucrania ha sido una especie de
viaje atrás en el tiempo.
De repente, la Guerra Fría parece haber regresado:
(27 de febrero de 2022: Putin pone las fuerzas
de disuasión nuclear en "alerta máxima"
en medio de la espiral de tensiones por Ucrania)
Queridos amigos, amigas, Rusia puede ser un
país empobrecido, aislado y tomado por la
corrupción, pero sigue siendo una de las
grandes potencias nucleares.
En términos cuantitativos hablamos ni más
ni menos que de la mayor potencia nuclear
de todo el planeta.
Por eso en este video queremos responder a
unas cuantas preguntas:
¿En qué consiste y cómo opera exactamente
la disuasión nuclear en los planes de Moscú?
¿En qué escenarios está previsto por Rusia
el uso de armas nucleares?
¿Podrían llegar a usarse en los campos de
batalla de Ucrania?
También, os contaremos porque las armas nucleares
ya no pueden proteger a Putin.
Arranquemos.
Tan atrás en el tiempo como en 1949, por
primera vez la Unión Soviética lograba hacer
explotar una bomba atómica.
La era nuclear del bloque comunista había
arrancado.
Desde entonces, una de las mayores obsesiones
de los jerifaltes soviéticos fue aumentar
más, y más, y más su arsenal nuclear.
Para que os hagáis una idea, se calcula que
los soviéticos acumularon cerca de 45.000
ojivas nucleares justo antes de que el Imperio
Soviético colapsara.
(Inicialmente la doctrina nuclear de la Unión
de Repúblicas Socialistas Soviéticas, perseguía
dos objetivos al mismo tiempo: la meta política
y la meta militar.
Bajo la perspectiva política, el arsenal
nuclear de la URSS tenía la misión multiplicar
la influencia internacional de este país.
Al fin y al cabo, ningún otro estado era
capaz de mirar a Estados Unidos de tú a tú.
Por otra parte, bajo la perspectiva militar
la idea de los soviéticos era lograr que
su régimen prevaleciera en caso de que produjera
una guerra que, eventualmente, pudiera derivar
un ataque nuclear norteamericano.
De esta forma, Los soviéticos estaban convencidos
de que tener más armas nucleares que los
americanos les daría la victoria final en
un conflicto a gran escala.)
Sin embargo, las cosas llegaron a tal extremo
que en la década de los 60, por primera vez,
las dos potencias reconocieron el término
MAD; la destrucción mutua asegurada por sus
siglas en inglés.
Y con ella la victoria dejó de ser un objetivo
y cedió el testigo a la disuasión.
Ningún bloque podría ganar nunca una guerra
semejante.
Precisamente por eso, apenas unos años más
tarde las dos potencias firmaron su primer
acuerdo para limitar la capacidad de las armas
estratégicas y los misiles balísticos.
Pero…
Eso es pasado.
Hace ya más de 30 años que la Unión Soviética
dejó de existir y fue la actual Federación
Rusa quien, por acuerdo de todas las partes,
terminó quedándose con todas las armas nucleares
del imperio soviético.
Y aunque desde entonces el terrorífico arsenal
nuclear ha ido menguando, el oso ruso aún
dispone de aproximadamente 6.400 cabezas nucleares
si tenemos en cuenta las cabezas que actualmente
están desplegadas, las que están en reserva
y las que están en vías de ser próximamente
desmanteladas.
Una cantidad - 6.400 ojivas nucleares - que
si bien están muy lejos del pico histórico
alcanzado por la Unión Soviética hacen de
Rusia la mayor potencia nuclear del planeta
por número de cabeza.
Fijaos.
Así que teniendo esto en cuenta la primera
pregunta que seguro muchos nos estamos haciendo
es:
¿Qué planes tiene Rusia para estas armas?
¿Cómo y en qué supuestos tiene previsto
utilizarlas?
Atentos.
1(LA AMBICIÓN NUCLEAR RUSA)
Por muchos tiranos que haya al frente del
timón, hasta en la guerra suele haber normas,
sobre todo cuando hablamos de un arsenal tan
destructivo como las armas nucleares.
Y, evidentemente, Rusia no es una excepción.
(La doctrina militar es el conjunto de principios
que determinan los supuestos y los tipos de
acciones militares que ordenan las acciones
de un ejército en función de cuáles sean
las circunstancias.
Pues bien, la última doctrina militar rusa
data del año 2014, pero en junio del 2020,
el gobierno ruso aprobó un nuevo documento
titulado “Sobre los principios básicos
de la política estatal de la Federación
Rusa sobre disuasión nuclear”.
Con este documento se actualizaron las amenazas
y circunstancias bajo las que Rusia se podría
llegar a plantear utilizar armas nucleares.)
Y la pregunta es, ¿Cuándo dice esta doctrina
que Rusia podría usar su enorme, aterrador
y aniquilador arsenal de bombas atómicas?
Esta es la pregunta.
En principio, Moscú considera que las armas
nucleares son exclusivamente un medio de disuasión.
Pero claro, la clave está en saber qué significa
exactamente el término “disuasión” en
la Rusia de Vladirmir Putin.
Pues bien, primero, según la doctrina en
vigor, Rusia lanzaría un ataque nuclear en
respuesta a otro ataque nuclear u otros tipos
de armas de destrucción masiva que se utilizaran
contra Rusia o contra sus aliados.
Luego, en segundo lugar, también recurrirían
a ellas si tuvieran datos fidedignos del inminente
lanzamiento de misiles balísticos contra
Rusia o sus aliados, o como respuesta al ataque
con armas convencionales de lugares críticos
del Gobierno o del ejército en Rusia.
Y en tercer y último lugar, muy importante,
la doctrina rusa establece el uso de armas
nucleares en caso de que un conflicto convencional
pudiera poner en peligro la existencia del
propio Estado.
En estos casos la preferencia siempre pasaría
por emplear las armas nucleares contra objetivos
militares grandes, como aeropuertos o grandes
bases navales, que aseguraran una gran destrucción
en las filas enemigas con un solo golpe.
Bien, estos son los casos en los que la Federación
Rusa contempla utilizar sus cabezas nucleares.
Pero, claro, llegados hasta aquí, la pregunta
que muchos os estaréis haciendo es:
A ver, Enrique, todo esto que me estás contando
es terriblemente subjetivo.
¿Qué pasaría si la OTAN defendiera Ucrania
o interviniera militarmente en Bielorrusia?
¿Podría Putin llegar a utilizar alguna de
estas armas si la guerra le va mal?
En principio, todos damos por hecho que las
armas nucleares existen para no ser utilizadas.
Pero lo cierto es que ya se han utilizado
y que si algo ha demostrado ser Vladimir Putin
es de todo menos predecible.
(Al presidente ruso le gusta jugar fuerte.
De hecho, una de las primeras cosas que hizo
Putin nada más llegar al poder fue aprobar
una nueva doctrina militar que amplió los
escenarios en los que Rusia podría llegar
a utilizar sus armas nucleares.
Por ejemplo, incorporó como caso posible,
el escenario de una guerra regional, en lugar
del supuesto de guerra global que estaba en
vigor anteriormente.
También, y esto es muy importante, se incluyó
la posibilidad de usar las armas nucleares
en primer lugar y no solo como respuesta a
un ataque enemigo.)
Incluso, los servicios de inteligencia y análisis
militar de Occidente, apuntan a que el alto
mando ruso podría llegar a plantearse el
uso de estas armas para desescalar una guerra
convencional contra la OTAN que Rusia estuviera
perdiendo.
Es lo que se conoce como la estrategia de
“escalar para desescalar”.
Ataco primero, destruir y luego negociar si
el bando contrario no quiere caer en la destrucción
mutua.
Esto es algo, no obstante, que los rusos niegan
tajantemente.
C1(“La comunidad de expertos hace tiempo
que insistía en que se publicara [este documento],
a fin de que no se nos acusara de mantener
doctrinas imaginadas por los americanos, como,
por ejemplo, la de escalation for desescalation.
Es decir, pretender utilizar armas nucleares
para alcanzar la victoria en un conflicto
convencional.”
- Viktor Esin, Exjefe del Estado Mayor y vicecomandante
en jefe de las fuerzas rusas de misiles estratégicos)
Lo que es cierto es que a medida que Rusia
se ha ido quedando económica y tecnológicamente
atrás, el protagonismo y el peso de la disuasión
nuclear ha ido cobrando cada vez más y más
peso en la estrategia de seguridad del Kremlin.
Al fin y al cabo, a efectos prácticos, es
mucho menos costoso tener al día las armas
nucleares y los dispositivos de lanzamiento
que contar con enormes dotaciones de equipos
militares como grandes flotas navales o aéreas.
Creo que con la invasión de Ucrania todos
hemos podido ver las enormes carencias del
ejército ruso tiene.
En otras palabras, si no fuera por las armas
nucleares, Rusia ni siquiera sería considerada
una superpotencia.
Por eso para Moscú, y particularmente para
Vladimir Putin resulta fundamental que el
poder nuclear esté muy presente en su discurso
político.
Y esto, esto es precisamente lo que explica
noticias como la que veíamos antes.
¿La recordáis?
(27 de febrero de 2022: Putin pone las fuerzas
de disuasión nuclear en "alerta máxima"
en medio de la espiral de tensiones por Ucrania)
O también noticias como esta:
N3(Rusia lanza misiles hipersónicos en ejercicios
nucleares para “demostrar fuerza” durante
tensiones con Ucrania.
Independent.)
No es que el presidente ruso esté pensando
en lanzarse a la destrucción masiva, sino
porque sabe que este es realmente su único
fuerte para intentar ganar influencia internacional.
Y como tal hay que entender este tipo de discursos.
En principio la doctrina militar en vigor
en Rusia no permite el uso de armas nucleares
ni siquiera si se produjera un enfrentamiento
de guerra convencional en Ucrania entre el
ejército ruso y tropas de la OTAN.
De hecho, lo que más miedo genera no es en
sí mismo el arsenal nuclear de Rusia, sino
la falta de mesura y prudencia que una y otra
y otra vez demuestra su líder.
Pero bien, ahora que ya sabemos cuándo Rusia
podría llegar a utilizar sus armas nucleares
y porque de una forma u otra suelen tener
tanto protagonismo en su discursos, la pregunta
es: ¿qué capacidades nucleares tiene exactamente
Rusia?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
2(DESTRUCCIÓN MUTUA ASEGURADA)
Tres palabras tan grandilocuentes como terribles
que marcaron la Guerra Fría y que ahora Putin
parece empeñado en traernos de vuelta.
Con todo, los arsenales nucleares de las dos
grandes potencias han sufrido muchos cambios
y muchos recortes en las últimas décadas.
En buena medida gracias a los acuerdos alcanzados
entre Rusia y Estados Unidos.
El último de esos acuerdos es el New START,
firmado en 2010 entre la administración de
Barack Obama y de Dmitri Medvedev [Medviedev].
Este acuerdo tenía que haber expirado en
febrero de 2021, pero dos días antes de que
concluyera Biden y Putin acordaron prorrogarlo
in extremis cinco años más hasta febrero
de 2026.
Ahora bien, ¿por qué es esto importante
y en qué consiste este acuerdo?
Pues bien, básicamente New START limita el
número de armas nucleares estratégicas que
puede tener cada país a un máximo de 1.550,
con 700 sistemas balísticos entre tierra,
mar y aire.
(Las fuerzas estratégicas rusas con capacidad
nuclear se componen de misiles balísticos
intercontinentales, diez submarinos con capacidad
de lanzamiento nuclear de las clases Delta,
Typhoon y Borei, y entre 60 y 70 aviones bombarderos
pesados.
En la actualidad se cree que Rusia tiene unos
310 misiles intercontinentales repartidos
en 11 bases distribuidas a lo largo y ancho
de todo el territorio ruso.)
Estos misiles, la mayor parte de tipo MIRV,
son capaces de transportar hasta 1.189 ojivas
nucleares, aunque solo hay unas 800 desplegadas
para su uso.
Actualmente Rusia se encuentra en pleno proceso
de modernización de sus armas estratégicas,
y se espera que para este 2022 podría haber
sustituido ya todos sus misiles de la era
soviética.)
Además también se cree que podrían tener
en servicio los primeros misiles Avangrad,
que es el primer sistema balístico ruso hipersónico
capaz, en teoría, de evadir los escudos antimisiles
convencionales.
Esta tecnología, que también tiene Estados
Unidos, parece el futuro de la disuasión
nuclear, y por eso países como Corea del
Norte también están intentando desarrollarlos.
Sea como sea, el caso es que en diciembre
de 2020 Putin dijo que para principios del
2022 en torno al 88% de sus fuerzas nucleares
estratégicas estarían modernizadas.
Bueno ya hemos llegado a esa fecha.
Se supone que es así.
[Claro que también hemos soportado años
de propaganda sobre la intensa modernización
del ejército ruso que luego a la hora de
la verdad se ha demostrado exagerada.
Al final los recursos son los que son.
Y en Rusia la abundancia económica no es
una característica nacional]
Sea como sea, es evidente que las más de
6.000 cabezas nucleares que aún mantiene
Rusia son el gran escudo de Putin.
El seguro que le permite apostar fuerte en
política exterior manteniendo el control
de daños…
Al menos militarmente.
Porque parece que la guerra económica y el
aislamiento internacional nunca fueron amenazas
tenidas en cuenta por el Kremlin.
Visto lo visto tras la invasión de Ucrania,
craso error.
Pero, llegados a este punto hay una última
pregunta que tenemos que responder, ¿realmente
hacen falta tantas y tantas cabezas nucleares
para garantizar la disuasión?
Pues…
Lo cierto es que no.
Según una investigación de Estados Unidos,
100 cabezas nucleares serían suficientes
para que un país se asegurase, incluso en
el peor de los escenarios, la disuasión nuclear.
Por cierto, este mismo estudio, pilotado por
un profesor de la Universidad Tecnológica
de Michigan, concluye que sería suficiente
en términos de disuasión establecer un máximo
de 900 cabezas nucleares entre los nueve estados
que hoy cuentan con esta tecnología militar.
900.
¿Sabéis cuántas cabezas hay actualmente
en el mundo?
Pues…
Aproximadamente unas 15.000.
Queridos amigos, amigas, Putin siempre ha
visto las armas nucleares como el escudo de
Rusia.
Sin embargo, la crisis de Ucrania ha demostrado
que eso fue un error.
En un pasado vídeo os contamos como los aliados
occidentales están tratando de dañar, erosionar,
incluso, destruir la capacidad económica
de Rusia.
Ante semejante ataque que puede terminar llevándose
por delante al propio régimen de Putin las
armas nucleares son completamente ineficaces.
Putin nos ha querido devolver a los oscuros
tiempos de la guerra fría, pero, ¿qué queréis
que os diga?
Los tiempos han cambiado.
Y por eso, en esta ocasión, y tal y como
ocurrió en Chernobyl con el famoso botón
AZ-5, las armas nucleares ya no le pueden
proteger.
Una vez más los errores de Moscú en Ucrania
pueden terminar llevándose por delante al
régimen en el poder.
Desgraciadamente, una vez más, los ucranianos
sufrirán las consecuencias como nadie.
Dicho esto turno para ti.
¿Crees que Putin sería capaz de utilizar
armas atómicas como respuesta a una intervención
de la OTAN en una invasión rusa a un país
como Ucrania?
Dejanos por aquí abajo tus comentarios.
Y ahora si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.